hey crazies the other day question clone
was asking me something why does the
earth keep spinning
the answer is inertia an object's
ability to resist changes in motion
thanks for liking sharing and
subscribing until you've said before the
Newton's first law only applies to
steady motion in a straight line gosh
you got me okay so just saying inertia
is a bit dismissive of this question we
need a deeper look if you take an
introductory physics class they're
probably going to tell you something
like this moving from one place to
another involves a certain set of
measurements which are governed by
certain rules going around and around
involves a different set of measurements
governed by a different set of rules but
I said something very important in a
previous video if your rule has
exceptions it's not that great of a rule
the goal of physics is to find better
rules that have fewer exceptions and we
do a pretty good job these rules
actually apply to both types of motion
they're just not very convenient the way
they're written let's start with
something deceptively simple this is the
ball no one asked you most of you
probably look at this and see what
myclone sees a tennis ball but it's so
much more than that
this ball is made of a rubber shell
covered in two nylon felt surrounding a
pocket of air each of those materials is
made of molecules which are made of
atoms which are made of subatomic
particles some of which are made of even
smaller particles which are just
excitations in quantum fields held
together by particle interactions all
just to make this thing you call a
tennis ball okay that was a little deep
my point is that everything is like this
including the earth if you want to
understand how these rules apply to a
rotating object then you need to look at
an object as a collection of parts
rather than a whole the earth has
several layers made up of a bunch of
different substances and because of
inertia all the little parts are trying
to move in straight lines if they were
allowed to the earth would do this we
know it isn't though so there must be
something else going on Newton's first
law says that anything will move at a
steady speed in a straight line until
there's a total or unbalanced force from
the outside if the parts of the earth
aren't doing this there must be a force
preventing it
that's renewed and second law tells us
that unbalanced force is causing an
acceleration X
CEL eration but its speed is steady one
rotation every 24 hours
ah but acceleration isn't just about
change in speed acceleration is a change
in velocity which involves direction to
a car accelerates forward because the
force from the road is in the same
direction as the motion of the car
increasing its speed the force on a
thrown ball is only partly in the
direction of motion which causes it to
slow down and speed up all the while
changing its direction too if the force
is never along the direction of motion
then you get circular motion the speed
never goes up or down the force only
changes the direction the same thing is
happening to the parts of the earth
while it spins but it's still an
acceleration and it's caused by
subatomic particle interactions
intermolecular forces and on the
largest-scale gravity but if you're
trying to describe the motion of a ball
or the earth you don't always want to
consider the momentum or energy of its
parts or the forces between them
sometimes you just want to say this is
the ball so we ignore all the forces
that only change the direction and just
call that rotational inertia any forces
that change the speed we multiply by a
distance and call that a torque you get
something that looks and works a lot
like Newton's second law when you're
trying to be practical sometimes it's
easier just to pretend and use different
rules there are a lot of science
questions like this the teachers just
dismiss away gotta need to drive you
crazy ask in the comments thanks for
liking and sharing this video please
subscribe if you'd like to see more and
until next time remember it's okay to be
a little crazy